for the first time since world war ii
the capital of the netherlands
is under curfew from nine in the evening
until 4 30 in the morning
people in amsterdam have been told to
stay home and on sunday
this was the reaction of many crowds of
hundreds of people
voicing defiance
i don't agree with the actual politics
in the netherlands
the restrictions of freedom and it's all
the hope
the media don't always show these
protests nicely but i hope we can show
that this is just a voice
a voice saying no we are so afraid that
we are going in the wrong direction
this is understandable but it's really
the wrong way
bars restaurants cinemas and cafes in
the country had already been ordered to
close in october
but the extra restrictions have created
an unexpected backlash
igbonet cloak i don't agree with the
curfew because i don't believe that it
will have a big effect overall
i believe that people will come up with
alternatives anyway
normally people would meet at 9pm but
now they will meet at 3pm
they will keep on seeing each other
parliament tightened the restrictions
last week to prevent a new surge in
cases
from a coronavirus variant first
identified in the uk
police were deployed in amsterdam and at
least nine other cities
nearly 200 people were arrested in the
dutch capital on sunday
where water cannon were used on
demonstrators another 90 were detained
in eindhoven where the central train
station in the city was attacked
and vehicles burned the prime minister
has condemned the violence
this is unacceptable every normal person
can only be disgusted by this
one really wonders what has got into
these people this has nothing to do with
protesting
it's criminal violence which we'll treat
as such the government has also banned
flights from south africa
south america and the uk and is
preventing ferries carrying british
passengers from docking
officials have issued a message telling
people not to travel to the netherlands
and the national lockdown is due to
remain in place for at least the next
two weeks
andrew chappelle al jazeera